like bill said my name is Jonathan I've
been at our studio for for about the
last three years or so and I'm really
excited to show you this because it's
we've been working on it for for quite
some time now and we are only just now
starting the show to show it to people
what one thing you should know before we
even spend a lot of time discussing that
is that if you if you want to use our
notebooks and you open up whatever
version of our screw you have installed
the chances are that you'll be
disciplined because the current stable
version of our studio does not happen it
books this is a feature that is we would
consider to be complete but it is still
in development so if you want to play
with notebooks you can do it today but
you'll need the preview version of our
studio to do it so everything that I'm
about to show you is available today but
only in the our studio preview so let me
give you an idea of what we'll be
talking about today we'll be talking
about some some background concerning
notebooks and data analysis workflows
I'll talk just briefly about about
notebooks themselves we will spend
almost all of our time doing a hands-on
demo this is a very interactive feature
and we will devote most of our time to
to showing you exactly how it works and
finally we will have some time at the
end like bill mentioned for questions
and answers so if I I seem to be
ignoring you please know that I am NOT
we're going to come back and do
questions primarily at the end so let's
talk a little bit about data analysis
workflows and by workflows I mean that
the way that you typically engage in
interact with are as you are doing your
analysis process if you are a user who's
new to our or if you've ever worked with
somebody who is like just getting
started with are you typically see them
using this sort of a workflow they'll
have they'll be typing our commands in
the console and then looking at the
result and the output of the commands
and then issuing another command so it
sort of had this ad hoc conversation
with our inter command look at the
output think a little bit enter another
command look at the output like and so
on and there's actually nothing wrong
with with doing with doing our this way
it's it's really fine for exploratory
analysis in the early stages but it it
has a very serious drawback which is
that it is not reproducible and this is
one of the whole points of using a tool
like our to do your data analysis is
that you want your analysis to be very
reproducible but when you're just
entering ad hoc statements you're really
not leaving a much of a record besides
your console history of what you did or
why you did it or what the output was
and so most people who have used are for
it for some time have learned that
instead of just entering stuff ad-hoc at
the console most of the time what you
want to use is an R script this is sort
of another level above a regular like
our console thing it's instead of just
entering stuff at the console you're
actually forming a script that leaves
our a record of what you have done and
this has a huge amount of advantages
over just entering code ad-hoc of the
console your your analysis is now
documented like you have a record of
what you did it is also now repeatable
which is to say that you can now run the
same analysis over and over as you need
to and it's even shareable you can you
can take this dot R file and send it to
anybody and say hey do you want to do
the analysis that I just did you know
there's there's no smoke and mirrors
here's the thing here's the thing that I
did so this is actually where where many
our users stop their their exploration
so they are scripts output done but if
you think about this workflow it still
actually has a lot of room for
improvement for one thing the our output
is disconnected from the input they get
your you are could this script produces
some output and it's it's really not
connected in any way to the script
itself you have to save the up it
separately typically this is not
actually the end of the line that the
the data and be the visualizations and
the the results that are generated from
your R code don't end their lives in the
our console or in a viewer window in a
in our studio they actually in their
lives somewhere else and in a document
or a presentation or or some other
artifact that you're generating and so
when you need to really perform your
analysis you sort of have to do this
export and copy and paste thing
to try to get the the results into into
their final format and finally the
documentation in an our script is
usually somewhat sparse if you if you if
you leave comments that's great most
people don't and there there's there's
often not a lot of context for why I
were doing what you're doing so to solve
a lot of these problems we introduce
something of a few years back called our
markdown it borrows heavily from some
ideas in literate programming and it's
it's designed to address some of the
some of the issues that I just talked
about our markdown lets you do the same
kind of thing you do it in our script
which is that you can you can write code
and then and have a record of it but it
also allows you to bring together your
output and your code in a render
document so that your document itself
and the code are are combined this
solves both of the problems I was
talking about earlier like not now you
can see your code in your output
together you can actually make your code
your final document there they're one in
the same artifact and we it is possible
to create all kinds of very high quality
professional documents from this and you
typically don't need to have another
tool that you export this to like this
can actually produce your final HTML
file or PDF document or Word document or
whatever that you need to need to email
out even though this is a very powerful
tool and it has received a lot of a lot
of attention and a lot of a lot of
accolades it still has it still has some
problems when it comes to interaction if
you look at where we've come from from
all the way from a typical new arla
analyst like this this is appealing
because it's simple like we by the time
we're good over to here yes you know yes
it is literate yes there's it is
wonderful to mix your your context and
your narrative and your code and produce
all these wonderful output formats but
something has been lost this is this
feels easy and fun and this this is
beginning to get quite complicated so we
we we set out to create a way of
interacting with our that
you a lot of the benefits of the
literate programming model and without
without a lot of the the complication
that we have in this so this is this is
an interaction model for our notebooks
you'll notice this is a this is a very
simple way to interact with our you you
run some code you see the output right
beneath the code and I'll give you a
much longer than these in a minute so
let me talk to her generically about
notebooks before I spend a bunch of time
showing you how they work just you can
get an idea of the philosophy we want
you to be able to interact with our and
kind of a single seamless stream and
what we what we mean by that is that you
you don't need to have four or five
windows or panes open you should be able
to have a single window open in which
you can cohesively interact with our we
wanted to make it possible for you to
iterate quickly under code and output
which is to say that you should be able
to change your code and see the and see
the change in output together in one
place again not not spread out not not
in a not in a big batch but but one line
of code at a time you should be able to
leave a clean and reproducible record of
your analysis in it in really a simple
text file and by this again we mean that
as you were doing your data analysis
you're actually creating like you're
creating the final document that you'll
be using to communicate and publish your
analysis and you are also documenting
exactly what you did so it can be
repeated
you'll be able to document your analysis
with rich literate prose by this we mean
that you can use all the power of our
markdown which includes many very high
quality professional layouts and and
tools for formatting your text these
things can be shared and published
easily and because it's just our
markdown you can export it to to any
format that you like very quickly and
easily alright so with that we are going
to spend the majority of our time in a
in a demo so please give me one little
will I switch over to the demo
all right so here is here is a our
notebook and at first glance it really
looks a lot like an R markdown document
because it is in our markdown document
however it actually has a lot of
affection has a lot of unusual features
that differentiate it from an R markdown
document so just to give you an idea of
what it's like to get to run code in the
notebook let me run this this chunk of
code now I'm gonna run it by clicking
here on the green button any you you may
know if you've used our markdown before
word that in an our markdown document
this green button would actually just
send the text to the console but you'll
notice here I don't have a console I'm
just showing you I'm just showing you a
notebook so I'll click this and you can
see here that it ran this chunk you
might have so you might have seen a
green flash that indicate that the the
code was sent to R and it shows me the
output right beneath the the code now I
can update the output just by updating
the code so if I if I want this to be
say I want to generate the numbers from
1 to 20 there we go so this is a bit
like to think about the way that that we
that you had that very first
conversation with R where you were
entering code and seeing the results
immediately this gets you back to that
quick iteration cycle that that's really
that's really a lot of fun without
losing a lot of the benefits of doing
things in a much more documented and
literate way you might notice that a lot
of what I'm saying is right here in the
document and that is somewhat
intentional
I've prepared this document as a as a
notebook tutorial and you'll be able to
download it for yourself after the
webinar if you like so don't worry about
missing anything in this document or or
trying to remember everything that I'm
saying I you will be actually be able to
use the same document to do a sort of
self-paced notebook tutorial when when
we are finished so a lot of times your
output from R is just a an object or
number or source single result but
sometimes it your notebook chunks or
your R code are also going to output
graphics so here's an example of a
awesome code that uses that uses
graphics
I'll run that you can see that produces
a plot again right inside my editor
which makes it very easy for me to tweak
attributes of the plot if I wanted to I
could change for instance what what the
size was mapped to and and and rerun
that if I want to so you can see here
you can use you you can use textual
output you can use graphical output and
really you can use just about any code
that produces output like that output is
just going to show up beneath the code
another another type of content that
that people are starting to use a lot
more is HTML widgets if you haven't
played with these we really recommend
that you check them out they offer you a
way to perform interactive graphics
right inside our studio right inside
your documents so here is a chunk that
produces an interactive graph I'm gonna
run the chunk you can see here this has
actually produced a an interactive graph
using HTML widgets and this HTML widget
just gives me a time series graph that I
can easily adjust with it with a nice
sliding window so I'm not gonna spend a
lot of time here in HTML widgets but but
just know that most of the time when
your code produces output of any kind
that output is going to show up right
inside of the notebook and we support
all the major output types that our
studio does so we've talked a bit about
output types let's talk a little bit
about what it's like to run code in the
notebook and I mentioned earlier that we
we we want this to feel like a sort of a
single seamless experience for
interacting with our and that means that
anything for which you formerly had to
sort of reach out for the console pane
we wanted to make sure that you didn't
have to do that anymore so one of the
things that you need the console pane
for is understanding what stuff has been
sent to our and what stuff hasn't so to
address that we we created this little
execution bar that you may have seen to
give you a better look at how it works
I've created this chunk here which
simply takes a little while to run by
having some seats to sleep statements
let's run this and see what happens
can see here that our studio is drawing
this little green bar on the side of the
chunk the the light green indicates that
that code has not been sent to our and
that and the dark green indicates that
it has let me run it one more times you
can see the effect another thing you
should notice here is that I'm actually
seeing the results streaming in real
time as the code runs so you don't have
to wait for the whole code to execute in
order to in order to see what what
output it's producing you can actually
watch in real time as statements are
sent are pulled out of the the queue
sent to are the results are returned and
you can see that output appearing in
real time
sometimes that is going to be sufficient
you just you'll just want to one run one
chunk at a time but sometimes you want
to run things in a little more ad hoc
way if you want to do that you can also
run portions of a chunk only and this is
one way in which the are the our
markdown notebooks like differ from some
other notebook approaches you might have
seen so they are it is completely
possible to run any portion of a
challenge as though we were running the
whole chunk itself so here is a chunk
that does a couple different things it
reads a CSV file containing a list of
cities and their locations and then have
plots them onto a leaflet map so let's
run this code just one chunk at a time
and see what happens so sorry one line
at a time
so just run this line and if you saw it
you probably saw a green flash there in
the gutter as that line was sent to
heart and return now I'm going to run
just this second line you notice that
now actually printed out the the data as
I as I requested and now I'm going to
run this third line here or the
statement I suppose and you can see that
that it runs the statement and then and
then shows me the output for that
statement now you'll notice here that I
didn't actually see the results for the
entire chunk when I did that when you
run one single law and it treats that
single line as though it were the entire
chunk so if I were to now click this
button and run the entire chunk you can
see it does both things now it reads a
CSV file it prints out the results and
then and then draws them out for me
so the idea here is that it it should be
very easy for you to take one little bit
of code execute it and see exactly what
that one line of code did so let me step
through it one more time so you can see
this line produces no output this line
produces a block of text and then this
line actually produces the map so so
it's very easy to step through your code
sort of line by line and see what each
line does without without needing to
jump into a of like a whole a whole
chunk execution mode so we've talked
about what it's like to run oh what
would one more thing this is sort of a
small thing but something that people
vast this word for awhile and we finally
finally took the time to do you'll
notice here that I didn't actually have
to select this whole will this whole
thing and run it and that is because we
now actually detect where your statement
begins and ends when you hit command
enter on the Mac or or ctrl enter if
you're using a different operating
system we now actually will run the
entire thing the entire statement
instead of just one line of the
statement and this is really to prevent
you from getting into an awkward
situation where R is waiting for you to
finish the statement but you don't know
it's waiting because this in this mode
you really typically aren't using the
console alright so we've talked about
the different kinds of output you could
have inside of a note but we talked
about what it's like to run code inside
the notebook and interact with R and
again you should think of this as a
really new way to to interact with and
have a conversation with the our
interpreter but one thing that you might
not be aware of is that our markdown in
and really by extension notebooks has
support not only for our code but also
for app for code written in other
languages so you're not actually just
limited to our chunks you can have code
in in bash or Python or C++ or a variety
of other languages here for instance is
a code chunk that is written in Python
this this just prints out the Fibonacci
sequence here I'm asking it to per have
the first 11 terms so there's no art
here it's all Python but I can run it
just like any other chunk and you can
see here it actually fired up the fight
the Python interpreter
and fed this code into it and then I can
see the results right right beneath the
chunk and this also works here's another
example this this also finds a
particular term in the Fibonacci
sequence using the are CPP engine so you
can see here I'm making an RC PP
function which actually takes a couple
of minutes because it needs to compile
then I can use that function here to
compute a particular term in the
Fibonacci sequence so the idea here is
that like a notebook is not just a way
to mingle our and your documentation and
produce something you can share like it
it could actually be used to compose a
workflow that uses tool chains and
systems from like a really a variety of
different a variety of different
languages so you can you can use a
notebook to create your data analysis
workflow in a very language agnostic way
even though R is sort of that the host
for your for your system so we've talked
a bit about what you can produce and how
to run code and like the ability to run
code in different engines let's talk a
little bit about error management so
sometimes your code is going to generate
errors it is it is just going to happen
we we have built a bunch of error
management features into the notebook as
well so here is some code that generates
an error I supposed to find error equals
true so that said this code can run
without without stopping the notebook
but if I try to run it you'll see that I
get this error here and this error
basically tells me what what happened
here so you know a couple things happen
when we get an error one is that we we
we color the gutter to tell you which
which line generated the error in this
case there's really only one line but in
many cases if you if you have a long
multi-line statement it's very helpful
to know which of the lines in your in
your code actually generated the error
so highlight that for you well typically
show you a traceback of the error which
which tells you where the error came
from
so if I click show trace back here you
can see it tells me I you called source
is called file and then and and what
when a file tried to open it couldn't
find it so we hope you find that when
you're up that would you encounter
errors again like you're not going to
need to dig into the console to figure
out what line of code generated the
error like bad information as well as
all the information you need to know
where they are came from is going to be
available to you right inside the
notebook so we've talked quite a lot
about what it's like to run code in the
notebook and and how and how to do it
we've heard of a line lies at execution
and about running the whole chunk at
once there are also a variety of tools
which I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on but you're not typically going
to want to just run individual chunks or
lines a lot of times you'll want to
bring your whole notebook into a
consistent state and we have built a
number of tools for for this which I'm
going to show you so it is very easy to
to run just the current chunk or the
next one these commands are very helpful
they will allow you to help to bring
your notebook into a consistent state by
running all the chunks that are above or
beneath your particular chunk and when
you do this let me let me show you how
this works so say we run all chunks
above and you can see now I'm actually
getting a little progress bar at the
bottom of the notebook here that shows
me it shows me what's being run and then
you'll notice here that I am brought
right here to where the error is when
it's finished so there are there are
lots of tools for for running your
notebook a lot a lot like you were
knitting an R markdown document now I'll
talk about the difference between
running code in a notebook and knitting
and in just a minute so I'm going to
switch now to our studio and talk a
little bit about how to save and share
these things
so here is our studio I'm gonna bring
bring my notebook back into our studio
here you'll notice that when when you
bring the notebook into our studio and
and open it it will typically max and
lies that the the pain so you you the
console gets out of your way because
most of the time you don't need it it's
still there if you do so you can you can
just open it up here and you can see
that when you execute some code inside
the notebook it is actually just sending
it directly to the console and you're
seeing the result here but most of the
time this is going to be redundant so as
you're not going to need to look at it
so I promise that we were going to look
a little bit at at saving and sharing so
so let's do that so if you are familiar
with with our markdown you probably know
that when you need to update your
document after making a change to your
code you actually need to completely re
render the document so there's this
command at the top called knit which is
what you can see like here's I have this
other document which actually contains
my presentation I in order to update my
document I need to knit which means to
re-render the whole thing rerun all the
code chunks and so forth in a notebook
however it is not necessary for me to
rerun all the code chunks to see the
document because if you think about it I
have actually already run these these
these chunks and I already have the
output of it available so in a notebook
you can actually generate the HTML
result without without running any of
your code all we need to do is is render
the document part and then put put the
output that you've already generated
into it so let me show you what that
looks like
so I'll hit preview here and you'll see
that here maximize this to make a little
bit easier to see so you can see here we
have here we have exactly exactly might
know my my notebook that I've been
working on and you can see all of my all
of my code here's there's there's my
sequence there's my plot there's my
interactive widget there are all of my
random numbers that I that I really
enjoy generating so all of the all of
the output and an input that I
encountered in my session is right here
inside this
and again this generating this thing is
not like generating an R markdown
document work where I've got to
re-render the whole thing whenever I
save the notebook this file is updated
so for instance let's say let's let's
say now I want to generate I don't know
maybe 200 secrets 200 numbers now I'll
save this you can see that it's going to
update here with a sequence of 200
numbers right on this side so every time
I update this thing it's going to update
the preview here on the right so you can
see these things are much easier to
iterate on than a traditional r markdown
document because the whole the whole
step of rerender is gone it's it's a
much more immediate system where all you
have to do is save it and it will
instantly update with with the file now
it's it's important to note that this
this file that I am viewing right now
this HTML file it's it's not only
generated when when I have that when I
have it open here this was actually
generated every time you save any
notebook ok listen one time again
because it's it's important to
understand when we later talk about how
these things work whenever you save any
notebook file we will generate this
there's this HTML file for you this HTML
file is basically the way that you can
save and save and share that the
notebook content in other in some other
notebook formats there's there's really
no separation between your code and your
output like it's all in one all in one
file and in our notebooks this is not
the case you have a very clean our
markdown document that contains just
your code but you also have this this
file we call it the envy dot HTML file
because we're not very creative and
could come up with a cooler name anyway
we have we have this this file which
contains not only your code but also a
beautiful rendered copy of your document
as well as the output so this thing
takes your code and your output and it
even contains the source code for for
the notebook so
you were to publish this to a nice open
this up in here so one second while I
show you what this looks like here so if
you were to send this file to somebody
here's what they would see wait that's
why it's System Preferences all right so
if you were to up if you were to send
this to somebody here's what they would
see you can see that this is a just a
nice rendered copy of my notebook with
the output that I've created and if
somebody wants to open this file like
work on this notebook that can actually
download the original RMD file right
here the RMD file is embedded inside the
HTML and what one wonderful thing about
this is that this this file that you
share with somebody is not in some sort
of like proprietary format that they're
going to need a viewer to open you can
send somebody one of these notebooks or
one of your rendered notebooks and it's
just an HTML files you can open it in a
web browser as I have done right here it
is it is very very easy to use and if
they want to sort of continue your your
your analysis it's very easy for them to
download the RMD and do that there's one
other really interesting trick that you
can do here for which I will switch back
to our studio so it's a so I just showed
you that you can take that HTML file
open it in a web browser it sits and and
I use that to to publish your notebooks
and really any any web host it's just
plain just by HTML but you can also use
this to use this HTML file to to share
with somebody not only the code but also
the output so to demonstrate that I'm
going to do something a little bit risky
and in this demo which is actually - I'm
going to close this our markdown file
and I'm actually going to delete the our
markdown file so here's the here's
here's that here's that demonstration
our markdown file that I've been working
with I'm just going to delete that file
all right it's gone so now all I no
longer have my our markdown file all I
have is that it is that notebook HTML
file so you imagine for instance that
somebody sent me this HTML file
our our studio when you if you open this
HTML file in a web browser you will see
what I just showed you which is a
rendered copy of the notebook however if
you open the HTML file in our studio it
will actually automatically extract the
our markdown file so that I can continue
working on your notebook as over my own
let me show you how that works so I'm
gonna click open an editor here and you
can see that my it opened up the our
markdown file and that our markdown file
just got created here
so our should you automatically took the
HTML file extracted that embedded copy
of the notebooks code and then produced
for me this this editing experience for
the notebook that I just had so this is
HTML file is sort of a magical
jack-of-all-trades you can view it in
web browser you can open it in our
studio and continue to edit and work on
the notebook it is a great way to bundle
up your notebooks and share them with
with anybody so let us talk a little bit
more about the the notebook ecosystem
here so I I mentioned earlier that
there's sort of this difference between
previewing a notebook and knitting an
are markdown document and I I hope that
I didn't give anybody the idea that
these are sort of two different worlds
and you have to pick one you can
actually use exactly the same document
to have a notebook and have a really
nice professional our markdown output so
you'll notice that in my notebook here
I've actually got two output formats
defined I've said that this thing is an
HTML notebook and I'm using the default
options for HTML notebook but it is also
an HTML document and what this means is
that I can preview it like a notebook
but I can very easily also render it
like an arm markdown document so let me
show you how that works I'm just going
to pull down preview and I'm gonna say
knit the same to HTML please ignore that
this is the
take a few seconds Samir recall that we
have a sub C plus plus in here and some
sleep statements but and here it is so
so this is this is also my notebook as
you can see it's got my two hundred
numbers in it it has my plots in my
widgets in it however this is this is no
longer formatted like a notebook I've
actually rendered it to a publishable
format I've given it a theme and a table
of contents this is this example is a
HTML document because that's really easy
to show inside our studio but it doesn't
have to be I could have written this to
a PDF or to or to a Word document or
even into a dashboard for for or in
really any of the other formats that are
markdown supports so my point is that a
notebook should not be thought of as a
as a as a sort of scratch pad that you
like used to like play with and iterate
on ideas and then when it's time for you
to publish you've got to open it up and
like some other like you've got to
create some other document and actually
do your publishable applet this the
notebook actually transitions seamlessly
from this simple interaction mechanism
right into something that is your
production quality output so not only is
every can every notebook be rendered as
a our markdown document but any our mark
10 document can also be treated as a
notebook let me show you how that works
so I'm gonna go create here I could
create a notebook or let's just create a
new our markdown document with it with
the defaults here so here's an our
markdown document I it's just a default
one for in our studio and you'll notice
here if I run if I run a chunk I see the
results right here below the chunk even
though this thing is not a notebook I
can iterate on these chunks as though as
though a word and at this point you may
actually be wondering wait a minute here
like I I don't know if I like that this
is not the way that I prefer to interact
with our markdown we have thought of
that and know that some people will
prefer using the console when they're
iterating on Khan code inside our
markdown documents and for this reason
we have built in we built in a switch so
if you really prefer to use the console
in
stead of having at the output appear
beneath the chunks as I've shown you
today you can just pull down the net
sorry the this gear here right next to
the net and say I want the chunk out to
be output to be in the console for this
document and so now when I run one of
these chunks it'll just show up in the
console instead as you are used to so
you have a choice you can use the
notebook style interaction model where
you can iterate on coding up but sort of
together in a single window or if you
prefer you can use the the multi-pane
approach like like you may be used to
you may be also be wondering if you have
to do this for every document if you
really really don't like the behavior it
is also possible for you to flip a
switch inside the options that will
allow you to there we go show output in
line for all all are marked are
documents again this option is only in
the preview and if you don't like to
know but behavior turn it off don't
create notebooks and you will have the
same are mark done experience you do
today we we believe though that most
people are not going to want to do this
because there's really just so much
power and immediacy and in this mode
finally I'd sort of be remiss if I
didn't spend a little bit of time
showing you how to create a new notebook
it's very easy new our notebook there
you go really this this this thing right
here is the key anything that has the
HTML notebook output format will inherit
all the notebook behaviors that I just
talked about it would get a preview
button which allows you to look at the
output quickly instead of executing and
rendering everything again it gives you
the the inline output regardless of any
other preferences you have set and it
should be a very easy very easy thing to
do
inserting chunks is quite easy come in
there's there's a couple different
shortcuts but it's very easy to add a
new notebook chunks tada so that's
that's what it's like to create a
notebook it's very easy to to start one
very easy to drop in new chunks and to
mingle mingle your documentation and
whatever else you'd like to like to have
in your document so this ends the this
ends the demo portion of our of our
webinar however
if you if you have questions I will I'm
I'm living this I'm leaving this open so
we can if we can to try some things
depending on what you'd like to do so
I'm now going to switch back to my
slides one minute all right so here is
alright so one thing I wanted to address
quickly and directly as some of you know
that the Jupiter notebook also supports
also supports our and you might be
wondering like what like is this like
how does this stand in relation to the
Jupiter notebook and the answer is that
we're not you know we're not trying to
create something that's identical to the
Jupiter notebook it just as we've just
selected a different set of trade-offs
so for one thing there's a different
interaction model when you're in the
Jupiter notebook model you have these
these cells which can be like mark down
cells or they can be our cells or Python
cells or whatever in in our studio model
you're actually interacting with a text
file which which gives you a lot of
benefits in terms of flexibility but but
also means that you have to worry about
things like de limiters to tell you
where the chunks in and begin so again
not we we're not claiming that one
approach is better than the other but
that they are two different ways of
interacting with what the pieces of the
notebook in in in our notebooks there's
first class of support for our which
means that if you are using are all of
your chunks are are typically going to
be running in our and there's some
support for for other kernels so like we
just showed you it's possible to have a
Python chunk or a bash chunk but our
implementation of that is somewhat
limited
for instance we can't display graphics
that were generated by those things very
easily whereas in in Jupiter it's it's a
lot easier to have sort of taught like
first-class support for other girls
hopefully we'll be able to improve upon
this but for right now like anything
that is not our for us it's kind of a
second-class citizen
whereas they they have suddenly better
support for it for other other languages
that are plain text format is a bit more
minimal to version control jupiter
notebooks are mostly just a large kind
of JSON blob
and you know the our studio notebooks
have the are markdown file and which is
a lot easier for you to check in to
version control you don't need a special
viewer because the they render as HTML
and again like I just showed you it is
it is possible to take your your
notebook and sort of cross render it to
a publishable format it's a little bit
harder to do with it the jupiter
notebooks um there are a bunch of other
differences i won't go into all of them
but those are so that's kind of a an
overview that might help you decide sort
of which which one to use if your if
your conflict did a couple things that i
didn't talk about but i just want you to
make just want you to be aware exists
there are different ways to control the
execution cues so for instance if you
have like if you're waiting for several
chunks to run you can remove and insert
chunks to run later i'm i didn't really
talk about notebooks in our studio
server but they are fully supported in
fact we now have a feature where you can
start your notebook running and close
the browser leave it running for however
long it takes then open the browser and
come back so notebooks pair great with
our studio server and our are a great
way for you to do your analysis using
nothing more than a web browser all of
the features of notebooks work very well
inside our studio server in fact we used
our server server to develop almost all
of the notebook features version control
which files check into and out of source
control obviously you have an HTML file
that's quite large it contains
everything in the notebook and then a
smaller our markdown file that contains
just the code it sits there are some
best practices there our website has
more information and finally a rendering
and hooks from other our front ends so
what and by that we just mean that it is
possible to like our studio doesn't have
to be the only thing that reads or
writes these things we've made the
format open source and one can build
anyone can build the front end so i'm
just putting this slide up again so that
you can I get a recall the philosophy of
notebooks you can interact with our
seamlessly your gonna iterate quickly
you're gonna lean leave a very clean and
reproducible record of what you've done
you can document it like with lots of
context using really rich formatting
tools you can share them you can publish
them connects with them to other formats
we think that they're going to be very
helpful
so we're right at about 45 minutes so I
want to leave lots of time for questions
these are two links that may be helpful
for you one is a link to the our studio
preview or if you just google our shoot
you a preview you'll find it I the
preview release is required to use
notebooks so don't don't don't send me
an email saying I can't find it of a
feature it's because you're not using it
it's because you're not using the
preview and then here's a link to some
documentation that we've written on on
the nova feature alright so with that I
am going to move to the questions and
answers it says so so one person said
what is the our studio preview Edition
so the preview Edition is simply I'll
just google the our studio here it is
it's it's a version of our studio that
is not necessarily stable it is somewhat
stable you can you can use it for day to
day at work but we primarily publish it
so that people are able to have like try
our new features before we unleash them
on on everybody so somebody asked when
will this be released so the the answer
is as soon as it is ready and it will it
will not be too long I can't give you an
exact timeline but we what we are
wrapping up this release and it will be
it will come out soon so here's an
interesting one so one person asked does
does our notebook work with Perl the
answer is is yes it does you pearl this
one of the alternate engines so you can
have a pearl chunk just like you can
have an R chunk somebody asked what
languages are included is sequel funny
you should ask
we are actually we we are working on
this very thing it is not ready yet but
but before too long you will be able to
have a sequel chunk as well as as well
as an R chunk somebody asked how does
the notebook interact with with version
with version control for instance the
Jupiter notebook does not finance
version control systems did yes yeah so
the way to think about this is that the
Jupiter notebook is
is a single file notebook right all of
your code all of your output I get and
configuration just lives in this in this
one single notebook file in our studio
we have a to file system so there's one
file which is just the our markdown file
it's plain text and that contains all of
your code there's a second file which is
a HTML file that I was showing you over
here and this thing has this is this is
a rendered copy which has an embedded
rendered notebook which is an embedded
copy of your code so if you would if you
want to use version control and you
don't want noisy diffs you can check in
just your code to version control and
this is what we recommend for most cases
and what that means is that if somebody
else opens up your your your notebook
from the version control system they
won't see any of the code the output
from the code that you've run they'll
just see the code itself and they can
run it for themselves if you want you
can also check in the second file so
that everybody also sees all the same
output but then you're gonna have some
some noisy divs and I look like I
mentioned earlier we are probably going
to be improving the the different system
inside our studio itself to make that a
little bit easier but for the most part
if you don't want if you don't want
noisy discs you just want to check in
the code not not the output HTML file
oh here's here's a very good question um
when you render a notebook is the house
has performed in a separate environment
as it currently is with nidar and the
answer is no it is not and that's that's
a really good question because it's
important to understand for the
execution model when you run code in the
notebook it's actually executed in your
current our session it is not executed
in some sort of separate session they
can't see any variables I'll give you a
I'll give you a quick demo to show you
to show you how this works and help you
understand it I'd say this so here's my
notebook again so let's say let's go to
let's go open up the console one second
so I'm gonna go to open up the console
one second here I get the wrong button
there we go alright so I'm going to go
open up the console in my notebook and
I'm going to create a
create something called a variable
called X I'll give that the value I
don't know 25 and 53 most of your
numbers so now if if I add a new chunk
in here and I just
perhaps value of x you can see there it
is so this is actually happening in the
same RF session as as your console is
you can think of sending the running
notebook code is running it right at the
console it's it's it's very similar so
somebody asked is notebook compatible
with any type of interactive graph the
answer is yes it is in fact here is an
interactive graph it is it is very easy
to to use interactive graphs any HTML
widget is supported not not just this
particular one so somebody asked can I
use this on shiny apps I oh this is a
this is a this is a good question
because the answer is that you currently
can't I said shiny apps dot IO is only
for it's only for shiny applications and
notebooks are not shiny applications
there there are markdown files and
they're not even shiny our markdown
files are just regular
like no server required like static HTML
static HTML files so those can be
published up they can be published to
our pubs or they can also be published
to like really anything that supports it
supports that static HTML somebody asked
what happens to interactive graphics
when you share the notebook output
that's it
that's a good question so um if you have
if you have used shiny shiny documents
or or shiny then you know that if you
have interactivity then you're typically
going to need a server to run to drive
the interactivity and so you might
rightly ask if I create if I have a
notebook that has one of these
interactive widgets in it what's going
to happen if somebody if I go to share
that with somebody and the answer is
that it's going to work just fine and
the reason is that the only thing the
only kind of interactivity that is
currently supported inside notebooks is
HTML widgets and those don't need us or
they run entirely off code and data that
is embedded inside the HTML so unless
you're publishing to a format that
inherently does not support
interactivity such as a PDF or document
the interactivity is actually going to
work just fine in fact I'm gonna I'll
demonstrate that for you so here's
here's our demonstration notebook that
we just made and you'll see that this
HTML widget which includes interactivity
just continues to work fine right inside
the web browser
there's no are required you can publish
this to any any static web host somebody
asked can you Intertek like equations
etc into the notebook that is a good
question the answer is not it's it's not
incredibly easy to do right now but that
if that is something that we are
currently working on so somebody asked
can we can we use our shiny server to
host notebooks and the answer to that is
not really and you there's really no
need to do it because notebooks are not
shiny so you don't need Chinese server
you can use whatever web browser
whatever web whatever host you want
alright somebody said how can I save a
plot from the notebook I right-click the
mouse on the figure to save but I don't
know where it goes
Thanks so if you want to save just one
plot from the notebook um I would I
would say don't there's really no need
to use notebooks at all you can
right-click and and download the thing
if you really want to but it like like
you like like you mentioned it doesn't
go anywhere useful so so what I would do
there is actually just take take the
take the take the code run it at the
console and then you can export that as
as an image however you like so the the
notebook is not designed to support the
sort of workflow where you're like
putting stuff elsewhere on the file
system if you--if you want to take that
like just one piece and export it I
would I would recommend just running
that that one
at a console and unfortunately because
the notebook works inside your main
environment you can actually get all of
your data set up to run that line of
code using your notebook and then you
can you can run just that line to jet
outside the notebook to use the to
generate the plot so somebody asked how
easy is it to insert external graphics
into the notebook the answer to that
question is it is it is possible to to
insert them into their rendered notebook
for instance you can just it's just
marked down right so you can just down
so so all you need to do is reference
the external image as usually would like
so but you're not actually going not
actually going to see you're not
actually going to see that see the image
inside it until you until you do the
preview it is easy to have an extra
language in the notebook but you're not
actually gonna see it in the editor
today that's something that we may we
may improve in the future what are your
suggestions for creating notebooks which
will need to be updated regularly for
instance downloading uh uploaded
uploaded data so the like I said the
notebook is just a static HTML file
however one thing that you may not be
aware of is that you know it is actually
possible to render one of these things
not just at the like not just using that
that preview click inside our instead of
our studio you could actually do it from
the from the our console via our
markdown render so you can do our
lockdown renderer and you can give it
the path to your notebook file and it
will render the notebook just as though
you had you'd rendered it inside the our
studio ide so you don't really need to
use our screen you to render one of
these things so if you want to actually
like have a notebook that that is that
updates automatically as time goes on
you basically want to create a script
that that runs our markdown render and
then put that script into a some sort of
like a cron job we are we are developing
a product that will allow you to do this
like very easily through a web interface
as well
you